Gorkoff: I started running in marathons to raise money
For research on Parkinson's disease in honor of my grandfather.
I always had the idea of ​​assembling enough people together
And gaining great fame through teamwork
Encouraging companies to take care of our activities.
- Allow us to be on the primary Android system
Reach people around the world.
They can help raise money for our philanthropic partners
This has helped spread our movement worldwide.
Keynes: It's really great to take advantage of your hobby
And turning it into a full-time job.
Torque is an Android app that lets you save
All the sensor data on your car and check the error codes.
The way it was used to publish it in the Google Play store
Managed to communicate with more than a million people have an application.
As the forums continued through me
The members of these forums told me what they wanted.
For my part I did what they wanted.
I am very grateful for what I have reached now
It is wonderful to see something I have invented
During my stay in the garden house cottage impresses many
all over the world.
[Funny Music]
TROIFIMOVA: We started immediately after college.
We were three together; me, my husband and his brother.
Our childhood dream was to invent games
That is what we wanted to achieve.
Since we released Cooking Fever on Android
The app was a great success.
We realized that this is our way to success
And that this is the statute that guarantees us success in the future.
In the first months, our app was downloaded millions of times.
At first we were only three people
Now we have become a company of more than 100 people
They create games that we decide to design.
This dream has been very successful and remains so.